Fox News propagandist Tucker Carlson
is now amplifying the conspiracy theory
that Elon Musk Amplified on Twitter
which he now owns yes the owner of
Twitter Elon Musk Amplified a conspiracy
theory uh it's a conspiracy theory that
goes something like this
um Paul Pelosi was in his underwear at
the time of the home invasion
which suggests that maybe it was
actually his gay lover who beat him with
a hammer and during the 9-1-1 call Paul
Pelosi allegedly also said this man is
my friend
um so therefore it's all an inside job
it was a lover's quarrel Etc it's been
totally debunked we'll talk about it in
a moment but now Tucker Carlson is
continuing to amplify this Elon Musk
deleted it from Twitter
but Tucker Carlson is single he was
pushed into doing that and there might
be something to that story let's just
come out with a piece that says and
we're quoting Elon Musk in a tweet
shares a link from a site known to
publish fake news true really what did
Elon Musk do well he linked to an
article about how Paul Pelosi called the
guy in his home a friend
well that's what the 911 tape says you
can draw your own conclusions or not or
maybe you don't care which is also fine
how is that fake okay so let's go
through this piece by piece and you know
the the sad thing about this is
it's the right Wingers who need to have
this stuff debunked not mostly my
audience but I think it's important to
arm you with the knowledge about where
all of this stuff came from first of all
it was two in the morning lots of people
sleep in their underwear that's why Paul
Pelosi was was in his underwear okay
very very simple secondly there is no
evidence that Paul Pelosi actually said
this is my friend the number one so they
keep saying the transcript shows Paul
Pelosi said this is my friend what they
have is the claim that the dispatcher
said to police over the phone
he says it's his friend
but then moments later the dispatcher
clarified to police he doesn't know the
guy what is believed to have happened is
that much like that Viral 9-1-1 call
where a woman who is the victim of
domestic violence pretends to be
ordering pizza
in order to not anger the individual
that is being violent against her it is
believed that in order to keep things
calm and not trigger David to Pape into
more violence
Paul Pelosi may have said something like
no no no we're friendly he's my friend
but it was made abundantly clear on the
call and the 911 dispatcher understood
that this was a violent home invasion
and that police were needed that's it
there's there's nothing else to this but
Tucker wants to continue quote asking
questions but as long as this is a news
story with public policy implications
and unfortunately that's what it's
become it is fair to ask the obvious
questions as you would about any other
violent crime that occurs in America and
especially this one since so many facts
basic facts seem to be in dispute local
KTVU investigative reporter Evan
cernofsky for example initially reported
that the Papi was quote found in
underwear when police arrived today
sarnovsky made a specific point of
retracting that claim it seems it was
just Paul Pelosi who was in underwear
it's the early details were not
completely accurate was there underwear
there was and Paul Pelosi was the one
wearing it I'm now told by other sources
that the Papi was not dressed only in
his underwear well okay fair enough we'd
be satisfied with either explanation not
really our business
but you can't blame and this is the
point you can't blame people watching
all of this at home for thinking that
maybe there's something weird going on
here yeah and this is a classic of
conspiracy theorists read Stephen
novella's book about skeptical thinking
you find it's called anomaly hunting
okay you find a piece of information
that hasn't been released and you claim
it's part of the story that's part of
the story that piece of information was
wrong so later when it's clarified that
that's not a part of the story you claim
that the change or the inconsistency is
a red flag and there's probably more
there uh you um find some benign or
irrelevant detail
that sounds strange and you use that to
amplify and say well we can't trust any
of the story because this one detail
doesn't make sense whether or not it's
true and again the question you have to
ask is not
what are the odds that Paul Pelosi is in
his underwear and says this is my friend
even though it was clearly a signal to
the 911 that's not that's the right
question when you when you when you ask
the question like that it's like wow
that doesn't make any sense instead if
you ask the question like this what are
the odds that in a situation as
traumatic and horrifying as a 2 A.M home
invasion by a violent lunatic with a
hammer uh the victim says or does
something that we from the outside can't
immediately explain or understand if
that's even what happened then you go oh
well that's super likely it's a crazy
situation
uh I mean I don't know what I would do
in such a situation then all of a sudden
these anomalies don't really make that
much of an impact on you and of course
they benefit from people not thinking
about things in those terms it was a
classic with the JFK assassination
conspiracy theories what are the odds
that on a sunny day
you have a guy with a black umbrella
just 50 feet away from where Kennedy was
shot under suspicious circumstances that
doesn't make sense the guy with the
umbrella must be involved and of course
we know the guy was the umbrella was a
political protest If instead you say
what are the odds that along a parade
route with 80 000 people someone does
something weird on the same day JFK's
shy it's like oh yeah well there's
eighty thousand someone's gonna do
something weird all of a sudden it's not
that compelling and that is exactly the
type of skeptical thinking we should
apply the chances that your login
credentials have been leaked in a data
breach are higher than you might think
but you can actually check if you go to
aura.com Pacman you can try Aura for
free our sponsor Aura scans the dark web
for your personal information login
credentials social security number and
sends you alerts sign up and you could
be shocked to see how many alerts you
get on aura one of our team members
found his login credentials in three
different data breaches now of course he
changed his passwords right away I've
told you before about one of my accounts
getting hacked scary feeling but Aura
also does so much more by automatically
requesting the removal of information
from data search engines giving you fast
alerts on suspicious credit inquiries
Aura has password management malware
protection for all of your devices and
Aura also helps you manage what your
kids can do on their devices by
restricting certain apps it's really
like a Swiss army knife of online
security and you can try Aura for free
for two weeks at aura.com Pacman the
link is down below